i make a comment a really a mundane
comment that everyone should take the
vaccine essentially and it gets national
attention alex jones went on a rant
about me you know i don't even know how
you hear his show anymore but he called
me a nazi
you know he plays it up big time let me
open this door and see who it is oh my
god look who it is
infowars.com
infowars.com
prisonplanet.tv why are you so angry
about the the [ __ ] vaccine i mean
just take it tell your listeners or if
you have any tell tell them to take it
and and and save their lives for god's
sakes what's wrong with you i mean come
on worship lord fauci wear a muzzle like
hannibal lecter well howard i didn't
think you'd become a damn nazi did you
howard do you ever like that do you ever
think you'd be worshiping the mangala
eugenicism huh
i think you guys are the nazis telling
people they can't get abortions i rebuke
you you monster and i tell you you will
see the power of god jesus will bring
judgment when is that going to happen
monsters
it is going to happen because i'm tired
of waiting did you have a relaxing right
after i pray for you in the name of
jesus
out of ten out of our schwarzenegger and
deliver the judgment of jesus
why can you sell those products of yours
but vaccines are bad i mean
no fda approval
if you want to cure covid you need
ultramecton x2 it's the finest dewormer
supplement on the market right now it
was designed for squirrels but it works
great on humans you got high entertain
earth you got tea tree oil manure
vitamin i cures covid boost your natural
defenses also works as a uh rabies
medication for sheep get a half off
awards dot-com
oh hold on i'm getting a knock at the
door here let me see who's at my door
oh look it's fun george soros what are
you up to fun george soros is quenching
his thirst for human blood
bill gates bring me my baby feast
wow an entire baby feast that's been
well fun george uh you know you just
ring your bell and get a baby feast
listen go eat before your babies get
called fun george thank you very much
all right enough out of you all right
well your show is entertaining as hell i
always say that because i see george
soros stops by and baby people you don't
see everywhere else
i must make an announcement here that we
will be doing a special afternoon show
next thursday with
eric clapton
[Music]
and he'll be performing his hit
anti-back single this has got to stop
and
it's just a fabulous song we're very
excited there are a few people i'd move
the infowars.com show for but clapton
denounced the pedophiles
and it's a no-brainer
all right well there you go there he is
infowars uh alex jones uh stopping by
our show to give his point of view he
says uh yeah you know he wants his
freedom he wants his freedom no one's
gonna tell him to take them out good
luck dot com
there you go
infowars.com
[Music]